talk a lot about a lot about politics
it's no secret that I'm a conservative
and when this year I really got into
reading about the red pill movement as
it relates to dating and relationships
what I found is that a lot of the men in
the red pill movement were politically
conservative not all but the vast vast
majority why do you think that's the
case
I think that well okay so I've been
asked this a dozen different times uh
first of all I'm not I was never really
a trump supporter but I voted for Trump
because he was a much better choice than
Hillary Clinton and I voted for him
again uh because he was a much better
choice than the you know uh
the dementia adult Joe Biden right so
I'm I I made the the best choice but had
like I can remember I got run up the
flagpole for this uh during the the
election season when uh when there was
the uh the debate between Biden and and
Trump and I'm like are these two guys
really the best we can do right is there
anybody else I can like sort of listen
is there another debate I'm missing